how are you feeling now I'm feeling
really proud of myself it was the
ultimate story of redemption on Tuesdays
America's Got Talent
as eleven-year-old violinist Tyler
Butler Figueroa took the stage and
shared his story of overcoming cancer
and bullying they would spread rumors to
say that my cancer was contagious and
they all wanted to stay away from me
I just didn't want to be the kid with
cancer so now I'm the kid who plays the
violin
Tyler dazzled the judges with an energy
filled performance of Kelly Clarkson's
hit stronger
[Music]
[Applause]
and now Tyler is seemingly stronger than
ever especially after this I would like
to say something on your behalf to the
bullies
I just feel so grateful that now we get
a chance to be here and be a part of I
don't know just making making dreams a
reality for these contestants I love
being a part of making dreams come true
it's nice to be a part of saying yes to
someone's dreams Tyler is the third
contested this season to earn a golden
buzzer joining singers Joseph Allen and
Cody Lee I love singing Cody is a 22
year old singer who's blind and autistic
and clearly has the gift of music Cody
and his mom Tina stopped by ET one week
after his stellar audition they opened
up about their AGT experience so far how
exciting was it for you to be on that
stage and sing for the judges it was so
awesome were you nervous at all no what
was it like for you mom and for the
family really to see Cody get that kind
of reaction from the judges also the
golden buzzer well first shocked I mean
even though you know even though we know
like his talent is just amazing still
you know you run into a lot of things
during his whole life of the music you
run into a lot of I don't know if it's
called stigma or whatever it's called
but you run into where a lot of people
when you say yeah he's autistic and
blind and then you know they kind of
have that face like oh okay
you know like singing right but then he
would blow them away so it was really
shocking for us because it was nice to
see you know the the judges just fall in
love with him and to really see his
talent